[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir des partis
politiques plus faibles moins de députés
la nouvelle loi électorale présentée ce
jeudi par Kate said vise à une refonte
du système politique tunisien l'objectif
pour le président et de parachever son
action depuis juillet 2021 il s'est
arrangé quasiment les pleins pouvoirs
nous irons sur place dès le début de ce
journal
le retour au chat d'un chef rebelle
exilé depuis deux ans en Égypte
relancera-t-il le dialogue de
réconciliation nationale avec la junte
militaire explication à suivre
et elle représente 90% des entreprises
en Afrique 60% des emplois formels on
parle des petites et moyennes
entreprises ce soir avec Didier à côté
l'un des plus grands chasseurs de tête
du continent et il est à la tête du
forum SME dont la septième édition se
tient à Kampala en Ouganda le 6 et 7
octobre prochain
on ouvre ce journal par la nouvelle loi
électorale présentée par le président
tunisien qui suscite de vivre polémique
après s'être arrangé quasiment les
pleins pouvoirs qui essayent vise une
refonte du système politique dont il est
d'abord réduit le rôle des parties quels
sont les changements inclus dans cette
nouvelle loi tour d'horizon par notre
correspondante à Tunis il y a bless
beaucoup de changements dans cette
nouvelle loi électorale d'une part le
type de scrutin on passe d'un scrutin
proportionnel qui avait prévalu au
précédentes législatives à un scrutin
uni nominal à deux tours alors c'est une
volonté du président qui a essayé qui a
dit jeudi soir vouloir que les élus ne
n'aquèrent pas leur légitimité des
partis politiques qu'il représenterait
mais qu'ils assument au contraire leur
responsabilité devant les électeurs il y
a aussi la possibilité de révoquer sous
certaines conditions le mandat d'un élu
s'il ne respecte pas sa mission ce
principe de révocabilité avait déjà été
évoqué dans la nouvelle Constitution
tunisienne adoptée par référendum en
juillet dernier donc l'élu de la
nouvelle loi électorale devra avoir des
parrainages de 400 personnes pour
pouvoir se présenter au législatif des
parrainages qui devront respecter
certaines règles de parité les fraudes
électorales sont aussi beaucoup plus
sévèrement punies que dans la précédente
loi électorale et un élu peut être
interdit de se présenter à vie si jamais
il est pris en flagrant délit de fraude
il y a aussi des exclusions des
exclusions des candidats binationaux qui
ne peuvent pas se présenter au
législatif sauf pour représenter une
circonscription à l'étranger et le
nombre de députés diminue de manière
drastique puisque ce sera 171 députés
qui vont représenter les Tunisiens selon
le même nombre de circonscriptions
correspondant à un nouveau maillage
territorial et non plus les 217 des
précédentes élections législatives alors
aujourd'hui les partis politiques n'ont
pas encore beaucoup réagi à ce nouveau
projet de loi électoral mais la plupart
des parties d'opposition avaient déjà
déclarés qu'ils allaient boycotter le
scrutin des législatives tout comme ils
avaient boycotter le référendum de
juillet dernier
Tom Erdimi chef rebelle emprisonné
depuis deux ans en Égypte et rentrer au
Tchad ce vendredi son frère jumeau le
chef rebelle timaner Dimi en avait fait
l'une des conditions pour sa
participation au dialogue national
inclusif et souverain qui se déroule en
ce moment à damena les explications de
Mamadou Dima
docteur
a regagné ce matin Djamena en provenance
du Caire il a été accueilli par une
immense foule de partisans proches amis
et sympathisants en présence des
officiels ainsi que de son frère jumeau
Timan Erdimi avec qui il a fondé l'Union
des forces de la Résistance UFR l'un des
principaux mouvements Rebel tchadien
l'UEFA s'est réalisé au dialogue
national inclusif après avoir signé
l'accord de paix de doigt d'ailleurs la
libération de tonnerre Dimi est un terme
de préalable pour leur participation au
dialogue visiblement ému et fatigué il a
appelé à sa descente à la paix et la
réconciliation dans un système
démocratique depuis 2020 Tomer Dimi
était incarcéré en Égypte et était dans
à l'attente d'un jugement prononcé ce
mardi 13 septembre
condamné à trois ans sa libération était
obtenue grâce à l'intercession des
autorités de la transition il a
bénéficié d'une grande du président
égyptien Abdel Fatah el-sissi docteur
tomerdimi 67 ans est atteint
universitaire ancien acteur de
l'Université du Tchad il fut également
l'un des premiers directeurs cabinets du
maréchal Idriss Déby Itno par ailleurs
son oncle il est rentré en dissidence
avec ce dernier en 2005 en rejoignant la
rébellion armée
un rapport alarmant sur la situation des
pays les plus exposés au changement
climatique à travers le monde parmi eux
10 nations ou les situations de famine
se multiplient 7 de ces pays sont en
Afrique dont le Niger on y retrouve
notre correspondant à roc Girard
la crise climatique est le dernier de
nombreux facteurs qui viennent expliquer
l'insécurité alimentaire que vivent
beaucoup de Nigériens aujourd'hui deux
autres des facteurs principaux sont la
montée des prix à la consommation et les
conflits armés qui font rage à travers
toute la région du Sahel depuis
plusieurs années maintenant la
sécheresse de 2021 de son côté à
fortement impacté les rendements
agricoles de l'année 2022 mais ces
derniers mois ce sont des épisodes plus
vieux très violents qui ont ralenti la
mise en place de l'action humanitaire on
a des problèmes des contraintes d'accès
d'accès humanitaires bien sûr à cause de
l'insécurité là on peut pas aller
vraiment parce que ce n'est pas sûr mais
aussi à cause de
des aléas climatiques disons qui sont en
train de se manifester maintenant avec
la saison de pluie parfois il y a des
zones reculées qui deviennent
inaccessibles après la pluie le rapport
de l'auxone souligne également que dans
les 10 pays en question le nombre de
personnes sujets à une fin aiguë en
moyenne à plus que doublé depuis 2016 au
Niger c'est près de 4 millions et demi
de personnes qui sont actuellement en
situation d'insécurité alimentaire
sévère c'est-à-dire à peu près 20% de la
population
et cette information que nous avons
apprise deux employés ont été brièvement
retenus jeudi après-midi par les
autorités maliennes des employés de
l'ambassade de France le motif de cet
arrestation n'a pas été communiquée mais
vous le savez les relations entre Paris
et la jointe au pouvoir à Bamako sont
particulièrement tendus depuis plusieurs
mois et les forces françaises de
l'opération barkhane ont définitivement
quitté le Mali le mois dernier
les petites et moyennes entreprises sont
au cœur de l’économie africaine elle
représente 60% des emplois formels
générés sur le continent et depuis 25
ans un homme se bat pour valoriser les
talents africains il est chasseurs de
tête président et fondateurs
d'afriqueurs et ils présentent le forum
SME dont la septième édition se tiendra
à Kampala le 6 et 7 octobre prochain
c'est le premier forum dédié à
l'accompagnement de la croissance des
PME africaines merci Didier à côté
d'être dans le journal de l'Afrique sur
France 24 merci à vous alors on dit que
les PME représentent 90% donc du tissu
entrepreneur en Afrique 60% des emplois
je l'ai dit leurs ambitions sont souvent
empêchés limitées par un manque de
financement et des outils qu'est-ce que
vous proposez justement
lors de ce forum de concret pour ces
entreprises en réponse à ces contraintes
que le forum a été créé nous apportons
trois choses première chose l'accès aux
financement vous le savez à peine 20%
des PME sont financiers en Afrique
deuxièmement l'accès au marché pour
qu'elle puisse grandir
[Musique]
on sait que déjà les financements privés
ont été ralentis sans parler du secteur
privé du secteur public justement
comment est-ce que ces entreprises
globalement ont traversé extrêmement dur
pour les PME en Afrique vous savez on
estime qu'il y a environ 100 millions de
PME en Afrique certainement un peu plus
donc 80% dans la formule mais sur ces
100 millions vous avez plus de la moitié
qui sont des très petites entreprises
avec un à trois employés qui sont
souvent dans la formelle et donc comment
vous arrivez à atteindre cette
population de PME d'entrepreneurs qui ne
sont pas identifiés parce qu'elles ne
sont pas enregistrées ces entreprises et
puis surtout dans des secteurs qui sont
des secteurs de services et vous savez
que la crise covid a beaucoup impacté le
secteur des services le commerce
additionnel parce que beaucoup de pays
avaient fermés le Lockdown le tourisme
donc les services de proximité donc
beaucoup de CPME ont souffert il y a eu
des mesures bien sûr qui ont été prises
par les gouvernements selon les
possibilités budgétaires de ces
gouvernements au Maroc en Afrique du Sud
au Togo Kenya mais glob le monde estimé
qu'il fallait entre 60 et 100 milliards
de dollars pour appuyer les PME les TPME
pendant les les premiers mois de la
crise et finalement on estime qu'à peine
5% des budgets des États voire 10% ont
été alloués à CPME alors que dans les
pays développés on était sur du 20 à 30
% des PIB donc des mesures massives pour
accompagner ces PME donc elles ont
beaucoup souffert elles souffrent encore
dans le même temps c'est le continent où
les PME sont très résilientes parce que
il y a pas beaucoup d'alternatives si
vous n'avez pas un business qui vous
fait vivre tous les jours et ben vous
pouvez rien faire et donc beaucoup ont
réussi comme à redémarrer mais dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
c'est le probablement les instruments
financiers qui doivent être bien à
disposition des périodes plus nombreux
plus divers parce que c'est pas
simplement la banque vous avez les 20
jours capitales le le le le les fonds
d'investissement etc et donc il faut
tous ces instruments pour accompagner il
faut les diversifier parlons maintenant
des des talents justement ça c'est votre
cœur de métier si je puis dire ça fait
25 ans que vous cherchez à convaincre
justement sur les talents africains qui
sont sur le continent ou à l'étranger
que vous faites venir comment vous
réussissez tout simplement les
convaincre que l'Afrique globalement
devrait aller mieux je dis pas va mieux
devrait aller mieux et offre beaucoup de
possibilités faut pas oublier que
l'existence d'Afrique soit je répondais
aussi un besoin c'est empêcher freiner
l'exode des cerveaux et encourager le
retour des cerveaux et puis les quatre
qui étaient plutôt bien formés ici
étaient confrontés à ce qu'on appelle le
plafond de verre c'est-à-dire vous avez
un bon diplôme un bon parcours à un
moment donné vous ne pouvez plus
progresser dans l'entreprise bah pour la
simple raison que vous n'avez peut-être
pas la bonne couleur ou pour d'autres
raisons et donc l'Eldorado que
représentait l'Afrique parce qu'il y a
un narratif qui a changé la croissance
africaine les technologies la
démographie bref et les investissements
publics en Afrique aujourd'hui
permettent d'encourager les cadres
africains à rentrer parce que il y a pas
de limite alors et en termes de pouvoir
d'achat on voit aussi assez rapidement
que leur pouvoir d'achat est beaucoup
plus important qu'on reste en Occident
et puis finalement ils ont envie de
construire le continent c'est ça la
question qu'est-ce que vous faites de
votre continent il faut contribuer et
une fine le lait de motif c'est je veux
participer à la transformation de la
frite alors c'est un argument qui
fonctionne assez bien absolument donc ça
c'est l'argument pour ceux qui sont en
Europe ou en Occident pour qu'il rentre
mais quid justement de l'augmentation
des compétences sur place que justement
qui est des nouveaux cadres africains
qui sont formés et qui soit formés dans
les différentes capitales africaines il
y en a de plus en plus c'est vrai que le
système universitaire globalement
souffre beaucoup dans nos pays et
d'ailleurs quand vous regardez les
classements mondiaux des universités les
premières universités africaines sont
sud-africaine à partir de 100 300 400 et
puis après on va dans les milliers les
Business School en Afrique ont réussi à
faire que chose extraordinaire c'est de
proposer effectivement les formations
qui répondent aux besoins du marché ce
qu'on appelle les soft skills ou
chercher un directeur marketing et
directeur vous en trouvez en revanche il
y a un vrai déficit au niveau des
profils techniques vous pouvez pas
construire un continent si vous
n'industrialisez pas si vous n'avez pas
des ingénieurs des techniciens même des
bacs - 2 techniciens des vagues pileux
et donc il y a un vrai déficit au niveau
des compétences techniques et c'est
vraiment là où les États mais beaucoup
l'accent et aussi réformer le système
divergents profondeur parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que d'abord
le système éducatif est en train
d'évoluer fortement et puis surtout que
vous perdez entre 50 et 90% des jeunes
africains qui rentrent à l'école
primaire avant d'arriver à l'université
donc il y a un déperditions massives et
donc il faut trouver des voies
alternatives pour former donner des
formations pratiques opérationnelles à
ces jeunes africains qui qui peuvent
tout à fait exercer des métiers
aujourd'hui dont le bâtiment dans
l'immobilier dans le tourisme il y a
tellement de métiers aujourd'hui dans la
digitalisation les codeurs qu'on trouve
par exemple Rwanda au kiné au Nigéria en
Afrique du Sud c'est des gens qui sont
formés en un mois et qui n'ont même pas
forcément de niveau Bac donc je pense
qu'il y a une réforme à profondeur à
faire des sommes éducatifs et surtout
privilégier les compétences c'est pas
juste des diplômes mais c'est des
compétences pour arriver à trouver des
débouchés sur le marché alors le message
est passé entendu merci Didier à côté
d'être venu dans le journal de l'Afrique
merci beaucoup c'est ainsi que nous
refermons ce journal de l'Afrique merci
à tous ceux qui nous ont regardé et en
particulier de Lomé à Paris en passant
par Abidjan rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur France 24
[Musique]